hey guys how are you I hope you guys
you're all doing fantastic get ready
because I'm about to just go on a small
little ranch and I'm sorry I didn't want
to do it but I just watched this
documentary and I got me just really
just real riled up like this is me
getting really reality anyway this video
was about the decline of kissing due to
stubble but really got me a little bit
upset a small amount of upset me being
upset this much a little tiny bit whose
guy Ken said it's not really his problem
if we're in pain from their stubble you
think that it hurts us do you care me
personally I guess not really because it
doesn't affect me there's gonna have to
deal with it well guess what buddy do
you know what it's like to kiss some
sandpaper to take your lips see people
just woman the sandpaper on the lips on
the face it's not a good feeling
it's like going out finding some
concrete and just taking your face and
just rubbing it on the concrete it's the
same feeling look at me I might look
sexy with this biscuit pitch so mister
cuz it doesn't affect me I don't care
not my problem guess what it's gonna be
your problem because I don't want my
face anywhere near your prickly little
porcupine man face this face doesn't
want to be near that face come on ladies
hi hello or guys whatever you're into
can you please just relate another thing
is beards mangling looking beards that
look like there is a small animal just
growing off of your face like it's
grapes meow because you don't even know
what's in there there can be dirt there
can be food there can be small animals
small children small Preachers monsters
now what I'm saying to you guys is if
you want our lady faces or soft man
faces to being anywhere near your face
please just do us a favor and just give
it a little shave I'm not saying that I
don't like to look at them a lot of
times they look really sexy they look
great
but they do not feel great if I have
just spent five hours in the bathroom
freaking shaving my legs for you let me
tell you what can you
maybe not five hours that's probably
over estimating a little bit and that
guy he said why would you willingly hurt
someone that you supposedly care about I
don't get it
it might look really sexy but I'm sure
so if you have some amazing kissing
stubble horror stories so leave them in
the comments below and I cannot wait to
read them I just don't really want a
scratchy face on my face
that's all see you later thanks for
watching my video I actually had a lot
of fun putting this on you guys want to
check out the documentary that I was
referring to I will put a link in the
description and I will also be linking
it here below in annotation but if
you're on your phone you probably can't
click that if you guys will subscribe my
channel you can do so over there too
will not subscribe button I'll see you
later